let's solve some quadratic equations by
factoring so let's say i had
x squared
plus 4x is equal to
21.
now your impulse might be to try to
factor out an x and somehow set that
equal to 21 and that will not lead you
to good solutions you'll probably end up
doing something that's not justified
what you need to do here is put the
entire quadratic expression on one side
of the equation we'll do it onto the
left hand side
so let's put let's subtract 21 from both
sides of this equation the left-hand
side then becomes x squared
plus 4x minus 21 and then the right hand
side will be equal to zero and the way
you want to solve this this is a
quadratic equation we have a quadratic
expression being set equal to zero the
way you want to solve this is you want
to factor them and say okay each of
those factors could then be equal to
zero so how do we factor this well we
saw in the last video that we have to
figure out two numbers whose product is
equal to negative 21 and whose sum is
equal to four so this would be a plus b
would have to be equal to 4.
since their product is negative they
have to be of different signs and so
let's see the number that jumps out at
me is 7 and 3
if i have negative 7 and positive three
i would get negative four so let's do
positive seven and negative three so the
a and b positive seven and negative
three when i take the product i get
negative
twenty one when i take their sum i get
positive four so i could rewrite this
equation here i could rewrite it as
x plus 7
times x minus 3
is equal to
0. and now i can solve this by saying
look i have two quantities their product
is equal to zero that means that one or
both of them have to be equal to zero so
that means that x plus seven is equal to
zero that's an x
or
x minus three is equal to zero i could
subtract 7 from both sides of this
equation and i would get x is equal to
negative 7
and over here i can add 3 to both sides
of this equation and i'll get x is
equal to 3. so this both of these
numbers are solutions to this equation
you could try it out if you do 7 7
negative 7 squared is 49
49 negative 7 times 4 is minus 28 or
negative 28 and that does indeed equal
21 and i'll let you try it out with the
positive three actually let's just do it
3 squared is 9 plus 4 times 3 is 12 9
plus 12 is indeed 21. let's do a bunch
more examples
let's say
i have
x squared plus 49 is equal to
14x
once again whenever you see anything
like this get all of your terms on one
on one side of the equation and get a
zero on the other side that's the best
way to solve a quadratic equation so
let's subtract 14x from both sides we
could write this as x squared
minus 14x
plus 49 is equal to 0. obviously 14x
minus 14x is 0. this quantity minus 14x
is this quantity right there
now we just have to think about what two
numbers when i take their product i'm
going to get 49 and when i take their
sum i'm going to get negative
14. so 1 they have to be the same sign
because this is a positive number right
here
and they're both going to be negative
because their sum is negative and
there's something interesting here 49 is
a perfect square its factors are 1
7
and 49. so maybe 7 will work or even
better maybe negative 7 will work and it
does negative 7 times negative 7 is
times negative 7 is 49 and negative 7
plus negative 7 is negative 14. we have
that pattern there where we have 2 times
the number and then we have the number
squared this is a perfect square this is
equal to
x minus seven times x minus seven
is equal to zero don't wanna forget that
or we could write this as x minus seven
squared is equal to zero so this was a
perfect square or this was a perfect
square of a binomial
and if x minus seven squared is equal to
zero take the square root of both sides
you'll get x minus seven is equal to
zero i mean we could say x minus seven
is zero or x minus seven is zero but
that'd be redundant so we just get x
minus seven is zero add seven to both
sides and you get x is equal to seven
only one solution there
let's do another one
let's do
another one in
pink
another one in pink let's say we have x
squared minus 64
is equal to zero
now this looks interesting right here
this looks interesting you might have
already you might already
a bell might be bringing in your head on
how to solve this this has no x term but
we could think of it as having an extra
and we could rewrite this as x squared
plus 0x
minus 64. so in this situation we could
say okay what two numbers when i
multiply them equals 64 and when i add
them they equal 0. and then when i take
their product i'm getting a negative
number right this is a times b it's a
negative number so that must mean that
they have opposite signs so that must
mean they have opposite signs when i add
them i get 0. that must mean that a
plus minus b is equal to zero or that a
is equal to b that we're dealing with
the same number we're essentially
dealing with the same number they're the
negatives of each other
so what can it be well if we're doing
the same number and they're negatives of
each other
if they're if we're dealing with
negatives of each other
well the
64 is exactly eight squared but it's
negative 64. so maybe we're dealing with
one negative eight and we're doing with
one positive eight and if we add those
two together we do indeed get to zero so
this will be
x
plus or x minus eight times x plus eight
now you don't always have to go through
this process i did here you might
already remember that if i have a plus b
times a minus b
that's equal to a squared minus b
squared so if you see something that
fits the pattern
a squared minus
b squared you can immediately say oh
that's going to be
a plus b
a plus b a is x b is eight times a
minus b
let's do a couple more of
just general problems i don't i won't
tell you what type these are going to be
let's say we have x let me switch colors
it's getting monotonous
let's say we have x squared
minus 24 x
plus 144 is equal to 0.
well 144 it's conspicuously 12 squared
and this is conspicuously 2 times
negative 12. or this is could
specifically negative 12 squared so this
is negative 12 times negative 12. this
is negative 12 plus negative 12. so this
expression can be rewritten as
x minus 12 times x minus 12
or
x minus 12 squared and we're going to
set that equal to zero this is going to
be zero when x minus 12 is equal to zero
you could say either of these
could be equal to zero but they're the
same thing add 12 to both sides of that
equation and you get x is equal to 12.
and i just realized this problem up here
i factored it but i didn't actually
solve the equation so this has to be
equal to zero let's take a step back to
this equation up here
and the only way
that this thing over here will be zero
is if either x minus eight is equal to
zero
or
x plus eight is equal to zero
so add eight to both sides of this you
get x could be equal to eight subtract
eight from both sides of this you get x
could also be equal to
negative eight so hopefully let's do one
more just to really
really get the point
drilled in your head let's do one more
let's say we have
4 x squared minus 25 is equal to zero
so you might already see the pattern
this is an a squared that's an a squared
this is a b squared we have the pattern
of a squared minus b squared where in
this case a would be equal to 2x
right this is 2x squared
and b
would be equal to 5. so if you have a
squared minus b squared a squared minus
b squared this is going to be equal to a
plus b
times a minus b in this situation that
means that 4x squared minus 25 is going
to be two x plus five
times two x minus five and of course
that will be equal to zero
and this will only be equal to zero if
either two x plus five is equal to zero
or
2x minus 5 is equal to 0 and then we can
solve each of these
subtract 5 from both sides you get 2x is
equal to negative 5. divide both sides
by 2. you could get one solution is
negative
5 halves
over here add 5 to both sides you get 2x
is equal to
positive 5 divide both sides by 2 you
get x could also be equal to
positive 5 halves so both of these
satisfy that equation up there